and the stylist lefty
gets a start on the mound he hasn't
started here in a long time
working out of the pen has come back
into the rotation as of july 5th and
suarez makes start number four
and fastball is
will throw a change up curveball and
slider rocky's one and three and that
ball is spoke to center field
i like that hey he's doing the king cam
yeah
so tappy at first and here comes brendan
rodgers
and that's a buck
tara has called for a buck
and gibson was lifting that right leg up
that right knee up usually when you you
is a left-handed pitcher when you bring
your foot behind the rubber ball
that's when it's called the ball
and this is pulled to third mayfield
trouble again
and he just made back to back errors
look how brutal this game could be
because yesterday we were telling you he
had a phenomenal weekend defensively in
minneapolis against the twins charlie
with six homers on the year two for four
last night
this is back up the middle
and there's one on the first not in time
charlie it'll be first and third run in
one out 48th ribby
for charlie
and that's fair and mayfield made a
decent throw but again krone got up the
line and because of that a second run
scores rogers comes home
two two
strike three called
that was off the plate but suarez
certainly needed a break and he got it
two nothing rockies
there you go here's austin garber making
his 17th start
second lowest walk range
if you want to talk you can't talk to
him clutches and bats base it to right
field
david fletcher goes the other way
fletcher at first
and ohtani that's a line drive caught by
connor joe
good read by fletcher
[Applause]
crushed your fielders yeah it was one of
those innings where things didn't go
well for you as far as you got the
pitches you made in the contact you won
it but didn't get the outs and that was
off a foul ball
and down goes connor joe so
a couple strikeouts now for suarez who
punched out diaz looking to end the
first opens the second
by getting joe one two
got him so suarez
figures
rather than put the ball on the ground
he might as well take it into his own
hands he's punched out three in a row
on the ground to mcmahon retreating off
his back foot good pick by joe out at
first base
wow not an easy play for mcmahon and a
marvelous play at first by connor joe
two-nothing rockies two three and four
for the rockies brendan rodgers suarez
was really good in the second one two
three couple of strikeouts and this ball
tagged to center field got a chance to
fly see you later again almost the same
spot as last night
brendan rodgers with number seven how
loud was that you know he's playing like
spilly he's playing like a guy who was
one of the top prospects of baseball he
really is there's two outs that now
bring up live
[Applause]
and that ball is lined to right base hit
story around third coming home
and the throw from lagarus is not going
to get him and mack read it beautifully
he goes to second and the rockies have a
four nothing lead but they're up four
nothing here and they may be up five
nothing in a moment mcmahon's gonna come
home easily elias diaz with his 21st rbi
stay hot elias
five-nothing colorado here in the third
otani line to connor joe
in the first inning 2-2 and that's a big
strikeout first out of the inning got
him on a slider that's the first
strikeout also of the evening for gomber
here's the 2-2
at the bottom of the zone strike three
[Applause]
went off speed
back-to-back strikeouts
justin upton
swung on and missed on a fastball
great job of pitching by austin gobber
there goes hampton
and the throw to second by suzuki
is not going to get him could play uh
getting over there david fletcher to
keep that for going to center field 14th
stolen base for hampton the rockies
continue to apply pressure on the angels
and this is bounced to the left side and
it's going to sneak through it now
hampstead will come home easily
rbi single rival topia make it six to
nothing colorado
joe man has seen enough he's on his way
out andrew wants is coming in sam has
started the last three ball games pinch
hitting for cj
this
crone
smothered the deep right take a good
look you won't see it for long
sam hilliard is struck and now the route
is on three run jack for hilliard nine
nothing colorado fun night to pitch if
you're austin gomber
and he got him to chase so gomber with
his fourth strikeout and he struck out
four out of five two quickly gone in the
fourth for the angels swing and a miss
strikeout number five for austin gomber
who works a clean fourth conor joe
looking for his first hit tonight pitch
is hit to right field pretty well struck
again lagarus going back and again can't
get to it ground rule double
ten nothing rockies on the rbi ground
rule double
tawny's over for two he's lined out and
has struck out sitting on 35.
oh
ohtani
way up there
36
463 feet
of distance for ohtani
angels get their first two runs tonight
it's now ten to two
colorado connor joe he had a double to
drive in a run last inning
and this is a base hit right center
field that's gonna score two
so connor joe with two outs his second
and third rippies of the night
[Applause]
2-2
got him
slider and that is strikeout number six
tonight
for gomber
0-2 pitch strike three called right down
colfax
strikeout number seven for gomber
colorado rocky's
debut of rio ruiz
and this ball
is looped into center field of base hits
hitting the thousand as a rocky
that's great
he's aiming for 37.
three-two
nope
takes the walk loads the bases
off the plate
faces loaded walk
and another run for the angels it's 12-3
in a move that just happened the angels
have acquired pitcher adam eaton here he
is his first career game on the bump
second angels position player to pitch
this year
and he takes the strike zone at 87.
even that's shohei approved gasoline at
87.
oh snaps off a nice breaking ball
that's a pretty good separation that's
16 miles per hour between his fastball
and breaking ball
in the air to right
and legaris is there and how about that
the era is pristine
adam eaton ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
and a comebacker ross cup will run it
over and that's
the ball game the rockies win it 12-3